he's Aaron Gordon magics forward joining
us on the Dan Patrick show I gave you
the slam dunk championship Aaron I have
you ever talked to Zach Lavine about
that Syme dunk contest yeah but did you
did you tell him hey I really should
have wanted to be a little bit more as I
went back now you know I think he
probably knows that I should have worn
it I know that I said over when it you
know I did two of the craziest of all
time well I see guys I still believe
that's all jumping over the mascot and
the ball under both legs is the best
slam dunk contest in NBA history
it just is plain and simple you know you
get the second runner-up is Vince
Carter's reverse 360 window that's the
second runner up for the first one
there's over the mascot how you do the
best dunk a long time still lose you
know neither here nor there
but you're over at Erin you're you're
you're you move past it right yeah I try
and move past it but everybody tells me
everyday you know you shouldn't
[Laughter]
how did you end up an uncle drew in LA I
was doing that boy celebrity football
fly football game in the after I got a
call from my agent and he said do you
want to be in a movie and my response
was hell yeah I want to be in a movie
why would I not want to be the movies
like okay well you got to be an Atlanta
tomorrow oh my god damn all right here
we go
so I took a red-eye didn't get a lot of
sleep they sent me my script via email I
pulled up on set you know and one of the
I guess was like a like a church gym or
something like that
somewhere in Atlanta and yeah I just
want to say no sleep a cup of coffee and
got right into it okay wait a minute you
walk onto a movie set you got shot
you got Kyrie you got Reggie Miller you
know Lisa Leslie like what are you
thinking Oh what was I think I guess I
think man I am so damn tired right now
well when I saw you after the movie I
said I hope Orlando's coaching staff
watches the movie and let you go all
Kevin Durant on people like you like
your character is you're called Casper
and I'm thinking why don't they let you
just play like that Aaron my family
members and friends were saying pretty
much the same thing they're like man I
wish they would let you do this in real
life because you know you've actually
got to show a little bit more of you
still saying this movie but you know it
is a movie but you know that's that's
some of the way that I like to play
played again you know I grew up playing
like outside I grew up playing on courts
like that maybe not so much like record
but outside and playing so when I get in
circumstances like that I feel really
comfortable you know I like having the
ball in my hands I like you know
facilitating and then when I get loose
who's the second best dunker in the NBA
right now
ooh game down so we talking about dunk
contest done students because there's
definitely a difference how about the
guy who don't send traffic the best
dunker in traffic is okay the best
dunker and traffic is Larry miss I'm
gonna say he's one of the best increase
in traffic okay yeah you tried to go
right up over people okay Zach Lavine is
a really good doctor in traffic to
Dominic Mitchell's also really good on
current traffic and so it's Russell
Westbrook less because you lose a dozen
choppas but we're gonna give it we get
to Larry Nance can you touch the top of
the backboard I like the top top if I
were to try and take a penny off the top
yeah could you not who could take a
penny off the top of the back
mmm-maybe Jojo hey joy oh joy would be
probably could really be guys you got
the mixer of that lettuce is in the side
he probably be able to take a penny off
photography backwards what's your deal
with the magic are you are you are you a
free agent right now it's a restricted
free agent oh you know Mia talks come to
life first you know I think I think
everyone is excited to get LeBron you
know so I think LeBron it kind of makes
everybody hesitate no just for the off
chance that you might be able to pick
him up but then after that you know
everybody's in talks and everybody's in
communication and it's hard with a
couple of different teams around the
league come July first
are you thinking of joining LeBron maybe
with the Lakers I think this restricted
free agent makes make things a little
bit more difficult you know I can't go
do exactly what I like what I envision
but I think Magic Johnson is doing a
great job and I think he'll continue to
do a great job but you know wherever the
Broncos so you think he's not a Lakers
well I I'm the one of the lone holdout
so I think he stays one more year in
Cleveland and just kind of figures out
what happens with Kawhi and Paul George
and then you got another group of free
agents the following year with klay
Thompson in it so I I don't know I just
felt like maybe he stays one more year
in Cleveland okay I think you gotta
dance to be honest why if their figures
out of this he doesn't know Cleveland
anything anymore then we left it burned
his jersey
he returned and got him a championship
perfect story I was um pretty able to
get out of there make himself happy make
his family happy so yeah I'm going to LA
but um were you on the set when Kyrie
got traded
Chris Webber and Reggie Miller were
talking about they were doing a scene
and they had their phones on them and
they started buzzing and then they
looked and it said Kyrie had been traded
and they had to turn to Kyrie and go uh
bro do you know what just happened you
got traded and then Kyrie left left the
set so I guess he could call some people
and then came back and finish the scene
were you there that day no I think that
was a scene where they were is out of
the club and they're dancing celebration
the problem told me you told me that
story you said cause it was so happy and
he ran out of the club they'd seen yes
you know like it wasn't even like
[Laughter]
everybody was clapping forward so I was
really good he was great he did great in
the movie there was a lot of a lot of
funny moments in there and look I'm not
gonna dwell on what Lisa Leslie did to
you
and that one you're gonna get grief
about that one ever given myself grief
about it like man is weak but granted it
is Lisa Leslie you know what I mean so
Lisa Leslie is gonna block pretty much
everybody shot you know she plays long
enough with you she's a decent what's
funny about that is during the actual
filming of kind of like the flow of
basketball you know we play about 80 to
85 percent Lisa Leslie was one of the
only ones on that team hit shot she was
just busted Matthews coming on I think
that suit really she's really the truth
no no I'm not too concerned about it but
yeah I'm gonna get a little you will
yeah she got a piece of you shot there
hey it was great and a great seeing you
at the premiere good luck with the
future they're in Orlando and hopefully
we cross paths again Aaron thank you
Aaron Gordon Casper and
uncle drew and he you start to watch him
out there shoot he look like Durant I
think you're going who is this guy
ya see ya you watch him in the movie
looks good you're like Dan let's do good
because at first I didn't know who it
was and I'm going who is Casper and then
all of a sudden I see him jump and I go
well that's here in Gordon like that's
all I needed
he's like oh that's hearing Gordon but
it for that there for a moment I'm
thinking only got some dude named Casper
there and man he's really good this
actor yeah this guy's really good for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]